you ever met somebody that's extremely
jealous today i'm going to talk to you
about the most
jealous spirit i've ever met in business
i'm patrick whether you're a host of
valuetainment weekly and today i want to
talk about the most
jealous spirit i've ever met in business
and what does that even mean the most
jealous spirit well think about it when
you think about jealous
individuals you may have worked with
somebody in the past that's jealous or
you might have somebody in your life
that's extremely jealous
what do they typically need a lot of
from you think about that
jealous people typically need a lot of
what
attention right you know when you have
kids and you have two of them if you pay
too much attention to one
the other one gets jealous it's because
you're not giving enough attention to
them
right so that can create a lot of other
things but
in business the same spirit the most
jealous spirit that i'm also talking
about is also the same spirit that will
turn you into a king
in your business or a queen in your
business if
you treat her right and if you don't
she will gladly go and leave you for
somebody else
who will give her the proper attention
she deserves
that's how simple it is and let me
explain to you what this
jealous spirit is in business it's
called
momentum now i'm gonna tell you
something about momentum
momentum is something everybody who's
watching this if you're running a
business it doesn't matter whether
you're in sales take not it doesn't
matter what you do
anybody in business anybody in business
who's experienced momentum before did it
not
make you kind of feel like you are
something that's
special and unique and you're not normal
because that that momentum made you feel
like you're almost not human
right maxwell says momentum makes an
average leader look great but a lot of
times what i've noticed is and i made
this mistake early on in my career is
the first time momentum came in my
career i thought she was gonna stick
around forever boom three months later i
lost momentum
i'll never forget this i was doing very
well money was doing well i had some
momentum
going on and boom she left me and i sat
there and i said how is that even
possible for this to take place
so the next time the next time momentum
was brought back into the business
i made sure she got a lot of attention i
made sure she was taken care of
i made sure i was thinking thinking
about i was making sure that she got the
right attention constantly
today in business when you get attention
from a momentum momentum wants to work
with you
you cannot take that lightly by the way
remember momentum the hardest thing to
do about momentum is to what to create
it
that's the hardest thing to do hardest
thing to do is to create momentum
then you have to maintain momentum you
have to maintain momentum
then when you maintain momentum you
advance momentum
so essentially you have some momentum
you gotta do a lot of front end in any
kind a lot of front in front in front of
boom you got momentum then you got to
maintain momentum so it doesn't go away
attention attention attention details
details details
attention attention attention then boom
advances momentum to the next level in
your business you could go into a new
territory new marketplace new city new
state new country
whatever it could be but if you don't
take care of this whole momentum part
coming and at any point
you start thinking it's all because of
you and you're the reason why you're
having so much success
it's not because it is spiritual
momentum that's around you you know what
momentum does
goodbye boom she disappears
and you sit one day at your office
saying customers were coming left and
right everybody was so excited what
happened all of a sudden
you took momentum for granted and she
left you
so guess what sit down get a paper and
pen it's what i do all the time
and write what did i do to create
momentum and do it again
but this time when momentum comes do not
take it
for granted maintain momentum advance
momentum
give it the right attention it deserves
because it'll give you things that you
never
ever thought you could do by yourself
without it things you'll never
ever be able to do by yourself but with
momentum things you can do that you've
never fantasized about
or you never imagine you can do with
momentum it's my message of the week to
you and please be sure to click on the
bottom to go to patrickbetdavid.com and
subscribe to my weekly newsletter
i'm patrick vader your host of
valuetainment weekly and today i want to
talk to you about the most spirit
most jealous who's jealous
i'm patrick baby you're a host of
valuetainment week but week be sure to
click on the bottom to go to my website
www.patrick
thank you for watching thank you for
watching